we're all here we're gonna begin with
this president Trump is considering a
radical change to American immigration
law just ahead of the midterm elections
in an interview with Axios website the
president said he wants to end
birthright citizenship which is
guaranteed under the 14th amendment to
the Constitution
now how ridiculous would the only
country in the world where a person
comes in has a baby and the baby is
essentially a citizen of the United
States for 85 years with all of those
benefits it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
and it has to end have you talked about
that with counsel yeah I have so we're
in the process in the process it'll
happen with an executive order that's
what you're talking about yes I didn't
think anybody but knew that but me I
thought I was the only one according to
PolitiFact 33 countries offer birthright
citizenship Jim VandeHei CEO and
co-founder of Axios was part of that
interview with the president for the
upcoming Axios on HBO he's with us from
Washington Jim good morning good morning
John how you doing I'm doing okay so
there's a week
there's election a week away and the
president is talking about this is is
this a serious policy proposal by the
president or is this something he'd like
to get in a big constitutional debate
about for a week to keep the focus on a
topic that he thinks works for him
politically I think it's something he
wants to do he clearly was surprised in
the interview that Swann's reporting had
figured out that he'd been talking to
white House Counsel about this I think
he politically he wants to keep all of
the emphasis on sending troops to the
border to guard against this caravan
that's it probably several months away
from hitting our border and so this one
he's been talking to
he says legal scholars internally they
say that he can get away with it we have
a 14th amendment which I basically it
states pretty clearly that if you're
born here on US soil you are a US
citizen and he says I don't even need to
go to Congress to changes I can use my
executive power to do it I think it's a
pretty legally dubious claim but he says
now I've got people that say I can and
by the way he has stacked the courts
with a lot of conservatives and I think
some of his confidence might come from
that and the thing with Trump you never
know is this an idea that's been
floating around in his head and he'll
actually act on it at some point I would
say when it comes to image
raishin he does feel he believes his
stuff even when everyone else says you
can't do that you shouldn't do that I
know other president would do that he
still does it well Jim went back and
looked and actually in in August 2015
when the president rolled out his
immigration policy in fact he said he
would do that he wanted to end
birthright citizenship so this has been
part of his plan on immigration for the
very beginning arguably was all there
for voters to see at the time but to
John's point if it's in part of his plan
for the whole time why is he just
bringing it up now one week before the
election he hasn't been able to do it
again we we had done reporting preview
before we did this interview for that
for the HBO show that we're doing on
Sunday and we heard that he had talked
to what House Counsel about this I don't
think they had planned on springing it
before the election I do think they want
to do a ton on immigration I do think
that they want to send a bunch of troops
to the border
I mean think about it we're sending
5,000 troops to the border we already
have what 2,000 National Guard we
already have border control we already
have walls and fences and electronic
devices and yet he's very fearful about
a caravan that looks like it's a month
or two away by the time it hits our
border could be 20 people could be a
couple hundred people and politically I
think he thinks that's a winner and by
the way even on that one I think he
legitimately fears the the illegal
immigrants coming in through this
Caravan
he watches Fox News Fox News plays it
over and over they kind of play off of
each other they get each other
riled up and then what seems like
propaganda or seems like politics
becomes reality in the minds of a lot of
voters did you get the opportunity to
what was the length of the inner I
wonder if you got any opportunities or
to challenge the President on some of
the rhetoric that he's used specifically
using the word invader which is also a
word that the Pittsburgh shooter used
yeah we had we had we'll probably air
the clip over the weekend had a very
very very tense exchange about that very
topic with the president it was
interesting
not to overshare on it like he it's
almost a more confrontational you got on
the language that he uses the more ideas
he is it's like he wants confrontation
he honestly believes I walked away from
that interview he honestly believes that
he has no responsibility to calm things
down to cool the country and in fact he
argues the opposite he argues that he
has a responsibility to his people he
always uses a current
my people to turn things up because he
feels like he's at war with the media I
despite winning the presidency despite
having the same favorable ratings he had
two years ago he feels at war he's at
ease as the country is on edge Jim
VandeHei thank you it was breaking thank
you